today we're going to talk about three
things that I wish I had when I went to
law school things which I still use
today as a practicing attorney so stick
around before we begin a little
background this is a case book you'll
get a case book for every single one of
your law school classes and a case book
is exactly what it sounds like it's a
book full of cases now I hate case books
why they're big they're heavy they're
expensive and what you'll find is that
the authors of case books are incredibly
lazy why well theoretically they're
supposed to go through the cases that
they include in their case books and
only include the most important material
in practice that's not what they do in
fact any practice authors simply include
the cases verbatim which means you're
paying hundreds of dollars for cases
that are in the public domain and you
can access for free these things are
heavy as a result some people will take
those wheelie bags that you'll see in
airports when I went to law school I
often tore the pages out of the case
books because I hated transporting these
damn things to class and that brings me
to the first thing that I wish I had in
law school and that's this a beautiful
shiny tablet technology has progressed
so far that so many of the tablets out
there are great it doesn't need to be an
iPad but the reason a tablet is great is
because you can access all of your cases
through the iPad and specifically what I
use is called WestlawNext it's an app
for the iPad now in law school you're
going to get free access to West law
it's one of the two major case databases
and what's great is you can go online
access your cases and read them there so
instead of transporting your big heavy
useless case books you can just bring
one tablet or your laptop if you want to
to class when you use a tablet to read
your cases they will give you the
bright-line rule that's the thing that
is most important about your case right
up front in the head note
and as a bonus you can use a good tablet
as a second monitor for your laptop
there are inexpensive apps that let you
use your iPad as an extension of your
laptop I wish I had a really good tablet
when I went to law school it would have
saved so much time it would have saved
my back so much trouble from having to
carry these case books around all the
time
so that brings me to the second thing
that I wish I had when I started law
school and that's this a really nice
laptop with a solid state hard drive a
long battery life and cloud storage now
every single lawyer that I know has a
horror story and they all go exactly
like this it was a week before the final
exam they had just finished their
outline for a class it was so perfect
that the angels were singing
they were about to print it out and then
the computer went dead they took their
computer to every repair shop in the
state but nothing could be recovered
everyone has a story like that and
that's because you're going to thrash
your computer around in law school spend
the extra money and get what's called a
solid-state drive it has no moving parts
so it's much much more stable your
sanity is worth the premium for the
solid-state drive now on top of that I
would strongly advise using Dropbox or
Google Drive some sort of cloud storage
your outlines your notes your
assignments they'll automatically be
backed up and it just looks exactly like
any kind of folder that you'll see on
your computer anyway so it's
indistinguishable from putting your
files on your hard drive anyway if
something happens to your laptop all
you'll have to do is log into your
account and download the latest version
finally a laptop it has a big battery of
self explanatory some law school
classrooms have plug-ins and some don't
sometimes you'll be in a study session
for hours at a time you never know when
you're going to have an electrical plug
in and when you won't so these days it's
pretty standard for laptops to have
eight nine and ten hours of battery it's
worth it it's so much better than having
a laptop that needs to be plugged in
every hour or two so the most part I'm
talking about Windows and
max why because you have to be able to
run exam soft and exam soft really only
runs on major laptops with normal
software on it your law school and your
Bar Examiners are almost all using exam
soft it's the software that locks out
your entire computer so the only thing
you can do is use a word processor for
purposes of your exam it's the way that
makes they make sure that no one can
cheat on the bar exam or on Law School
finals so it's important to have a
computer that can run that soft
otherwise you will be totally screwed
when it comes to the final exam so that
brings me to the third thing that I wish
I had in law school and that is a fast
cheap laser printer now back in the day
laser printers were the size of VW
beetles and they cost more than a new
kidney now they're the size of toasters
and cost about seven dollars you can
pick up a reasonably fast laser printer
with a built-in scanner for less than
$200 in law school you are going to be
printing a ton whether it's your
outlines your notes or flashcards you're
going to be printing a lot and you want
a printer that can handle that what's
great about a laser printer is that it's
unaffected by water which is great
because you're going to be drinking a
lot and you might happen to spill on
your notes which is the last thing you
want it can get a laser printer with a
built-in scanner even better those are
the three things that I wish I had when
I started law school I use those three
things every day in practice technology
has progressed so fast there's so many
good tablets out there are so many good
laptops and so many good printers if you
make the investment upfront if you don't
already have those things when you start
law school you'll be glad that you did
they're going to make your life so much
easier and that's a huge part of
succeeding in law school oh and one last
thing if you're getting ready for law
school check this out we put together a
free ebook called the ultimate free law
checklist just click the link below to
download it some of our best tips and
strategies for getting ahead before you
start law school and it will put new
miles ahead of your classmates just
click below and also if you like this
video please subscribe to our Channel we
come out with new videos on how to crush
law school all the time so thanks a lot
thanks for stopping by
[Music]
[Music]